elle est surnommée la comète défaite
parce qu'elle sera le plus près de la
terre autour du 20 décembre ea sont plus
lumineux en fin de semaine là il passe
près de notre soleil le 8 décembre
on espère que le soleil va la faire
fondre suffisamment pour qu'on puisse
étudier justement la queue de la comète
un véritable cadeau pour les astronomes
oui c'est excitant pour un
astrophysicien
c'est excitant parce que ça nous permet
de confirmer beaucoup de théories en
fait on ignore d'où elle vient mais la
comète de i borissov baptisé en
l'honneur de celui qui l'a découverte en
août dernier et la première qui
officiellement ne provient pas de notre
système solaire étudier les comètes nous
renseigne sur le l'origine de ces
molécules hla et de la vie possible sur
des planètes extra solaires ou des
planètes comme la terre
c'est une façon donc de comparer la
structure la composition chimique de ces
objets formé ailleurs dans le cosmos
avec ce qui existe dans notre propre
système solaire la science fonctionne de
cette façon c'est en se comparant qu'on
arrive à ceux à mieux se comprendre mais
le spectacle ne risque pas d'être
sensationnel ni accessible à tous
malheureusement ce n'est pas un objet
qui est visible à l'oeil nu puis ça
prend plus qu'une petite paire de
jumelles on espère pouvoir l'observer
qu'un télescope comme ce cil le mieux
c'est peut-être de l'observer sur
internet là où plusieurs experts
partageront leurs connaissances sur ce
morceau de castets de l'univers je
dirais que c'est pour les geeks
oui c'est pour les geeks les mordus
d'astronomie issigeac audrey charbonneau
radio canada mon frère